a high level meeting in lev to talk
about the war and its impact around the
world
president volody mircilenski meeting
with turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan and the u.n secretary general
antonio guterres
discussing the importance of continuing
to export ukrainian grain to the world
through a humanitarian corridor
also the situation on the ground at the
nuclear power plant in sao paulo still a
major concern occupied by russian forces
since march and with fighting now
increasing fears of a major nuclear
incident
military equipment and personnel should
be withdrawn from the plant
further deployment of forces or
equipment to the site must be avoided
the area needs to be demilitarized
and we must tell it
as it is
any potential damage to zaporizia is
suicide
the presence of pressing an adult one
here in levive is seen by many as a new
opportunity for progress a key player in
getting the sites to strike the landmark
deal on grain exports erdogan used his
first visit to levi to repeat the need
for continued diplomacy
i personally believe that the war will
come to an end at the negotiating table
it all comes down to finding the fastest
and easiest way to the negotiating table
president
welcomed turkey support but restated his
position on talks at this point
there is no trust towards the russian
federation i believe that in this
diplomatic window there is russian
weaponry that's why i'm surprised to
hear that they'd be ready for some kind
of peace people that kill rape every day
shoot cruise missiles onto our peaceful
cities and infrastructure cannot want
peace that's why first of all they must
withdraw their troops from our territory
and only then
as fighting continues to rage in
ukraine's southern and eastern regions
civilians continue to die in what keith
says are targeted russian attacks on
residential areas
it's been almost six months since the
war began and thousands of people
continue to be evacuated injured and
killed and that's why it's crucial to
find a way to a cease fire to prevent
further loss of life there is ukraine